there it is i'm just
amelia so firstly amelia thank you for
hooking thank you for hooking us up
she's gone anyway
and so what was your name maria meisner
oh that's so cool listen folks it's just
been really good
seeing your story on social media thank
you for the the positivity
and the support it's been great to
um have been able to be a little help
along the way
you've got your dog and everything as
well that's i'm loving that yeah
oh nice family love that so yeah i mean
honestly
i've been following you guys for a while
i don't know if we've we i don't think
we physically met
no never physically man so literally all
of the
advice and training that you've got has
just been on youtube and stuff
yeah i think it was two of your videos
maybe one video wasn't it two videos
yeah yeah we watched two of your videos
one night on a friday we're having a
glass of wine and
who's this guy shouting you about
property and what the hell's meant to
rent
and from that video we were kind of
hooked man we watched it like four in
the morning we watched the eviction
and we've had a holiday books for
budapest so we went there
for two weeks and then we came back and
saw within two months we were
two thousand pound a month better off
that's insane
that is absolutely insane we did like we
did like a jv with another guy from your
facebook
group yeah and we just lent him some
money i think it's about three thousand
pounds
uh within those two months he paid us
back with 20 on top
and he also pays us between 150 and 400
pounds a month
for the next five years so that one's
completely passive
that's brilliant fantastic yeah it's
just from learning you know just just
what you're saying
knowing it it actually exists you know
because we didn't have a clue about
rendering that
it's possible that it's legal you know
police options
no idea we read um rich dad called that
we
we read the kiyosaki kiyosaki book then
we read
um literally guy on facebook
uh it was giving it away for free and
i'm like yeah
i want to get into property always
wanted so yeah i'm collecting it
and the only terms he had is you can
have it for free
if you pass it on to somebody once you
read it and you
took something for yourself from it you
know yeah that's really good
yeah what sorry which books which book
was that
magic oh yeah simon sushi simon zeus she
actually
got me started in property and robert
kiyosaki yeah
so it's great you know it's really you
from youtube really
because after that reading that book it
was just a
half a page about rent to end in simon's
book
so we were like what the hell is that
you know is it even legal is it
subletting
a war and then we we just one night
evening really getting uh a drink
and watching property stuff so we
watched a few other videos how people
are going for viewings and things like
that and then we found your video
you're shouting about property
it's that easy and like how is that
person you know
i think the hardest part to swallow was
that we we owned a
maintenance company anyway we were
working for countrywide and some other
large letting agents and we still didn't
know what rent
was so the amount of times i've been in
and out of all these estate agents
asking for work picking up job sheets
you know giving it to our staff
and i could have just taken the
properties ourselves really and we just
didn't know
people say if you want to learn about
property you know
all you have to do is go and work for an
estate agencies or whatever but i don't
agree with that i worked as an estate
agent and
it's a different you might learn about
property but you're not going to learn
about how to make money in property
exactly yeah yeah and to do that
to do that you gotta you've gotta watch
videos and read books and attend
seminars from people that actually made
money
yes definitely definitely yeah all of
them
at the end ripped us off yeah yeah it's
so difficult to make money as a
contractor for a latin agent and then
you've got to
90 days you're always waiting for more
than you've got if that makes sense
um from from your property entrepreneur
stuff now then
from what we've done since some of your
videos just shy of three and a half k a
month
and we probably work three or four hours
a month on it because we've systemized
the whole thing
um just from i've built hmos
economics very bad profession and i
built a lot of larger hmos for
investors before i knew about really
property and so we
knew things like stick digital doors put
the key
side aside and whether you've been able
to use docusign you can
effectively check tenants in without
going anywhere so we've been doing it
all from home
we've got one room that's just going
through changing over but we've been
full occupancy through the whole
pandemic as well great
that's incredible and and where are you
guys based not singing them
okay great support me through them
yeah yeah yeah i know the area i'm a
midlands boy myself so i know
and there's article 4 in nottingham
right yes we're in
the villages around them oh right that's
how you got around it
you know or there's really good
connections we've got the skylink which
goes to eastman's airport and stuff
yeah i mean once we've
seven to ten days they're full so so
when did you
start watching my videos on youtube
earlier last year yeah so so it's now
been what like
in eight nine months yeah the thing is
we did the first two
we got the the first one actually we've
been in the property before 18 months
ago
we did some maintenance for it for an
older landlady and
maria recognized the photographs on
comfy so i had a phone number
it was through an agent i rang it
directly and within four days we signed
a management agreement and we checked
her old tenant out
because she was re-advertising it so we
did that for her we just
off the letter yeah gave it to us
straight away because i already had a
bit of rapport with ec
yeah sort of i showed her a rental
comparison scheme i'd made so
she'd see that she was better off net a
month but
with us and she gave us the keys to it
and we never looked back
that's the first deal we did and that
one nets was about 996
income per month off a four bed how much
money did you have to put down
to get that deal oh well because uh
we've no closet no
we paid her the month up front which is
800 pounds
and we probably spent about three
thousand on it maybe just a little bit
less
because we did a lot of the work
ourselves i mean we fixed our tvs
we really went high end with it and it
grows
about 2080 at the top but we only pay
the landlady 800 so
obviously quite a big margin let me ask
you something because you've what you've
immersed yourself in
in my youtube videos you learned about
rent to rent you went and got some i put
a little
portfolio right to wrench you're making
three and a half thousand pounds a month
you spend a few hours a month managing
that so it's pretty
passive most people that you say that to
would say that sounds too good to be
true and they'll say everything
to be true it usually is and i know that
you you
sometimes people have been commenting on
my facebook and saying stuff like
or on youtube and saying all right
stupid you should be telling people
dreams and i've seen you jump
and say actually we've we've actually
done this
you know
after asking everybody and literally
everybody looking on one tray off
and then just asking everybody would you
consider the company
people say yeah come come chat with us
you know
they didn't have any like any problems
with it
no to be fair we've turned down more
than we've taken because we haven't just
been quite right i mean i don't want a
portfolio over a load of
maybe making money you know we want to
make sure that these things are going to
stand the test of time for five years
and they are through this pandemic which
is
kind of we were really unsure about
whether we were going to survive
i know a lot of people have a lot of
people leaving house and going back home
and stuff and leaving rooms
yeah and positive cash flow the whole
way through it i think the pandemic is
going to help hmos
i think it's good it's gonna and and the
reason that people have struggled
with some hmos i've had some of my
students that have struggled is because
they've sadly been unlucky and they've
had people move out
and because of lockdown they can't
remarket the rooms because you can't
so then they're stuck with properties
however
we saw the demand in most of our areas
just dropped off eclipse sort of
overnight
you were getting maybe one or two views
of room where we were getting 40 or 15
areas usually but actually however
the last house that we've done
we literally finished before the
lockdown like a day or
two days before but people came to view
the property while we were still
refurbing it
so we have three tenants moving in
during the week
no yeah but but here's the thing
as people have less job security and are
trying to cut down their expenses people
are going to downsize and they're going
to move into
house shares so i think there's an
overpopulation
of people and with article 4 coming in
it's really limiting the amount of
people that can start up hmos unless you
really know what you're doing
yes yes i think as well with the student
market at the moment i think there might
be
quite a few empty student properties
that will be coming especially in
nottingham it's
quite long having a large student base
and a lot of them have gone back and i
don't know whether they're going to
start the courses again this year so
what i'm looking to do you know yeah so
what's the plan
now then you're making you're making
three and a half thousand pound a month
it's pretty much passive
what's the plan now are you gonna scale
are you gonna just enjoy life are you
going to start well
yeah i mean we were going to buy weren't
we anyway i think you'd probably
have a lot more if not because we were
going in like one
month once we did the first two and then
the jv we had like christmas off we just
because we've worked so hard over the
last two years running the company
we just downscaled it completely we got
we had a huge unit we had advanced staff
up the lot
we just cut it right back i don't know
if you follow tony robbins i've read a
lot of this stuff lately
it's not about how much you make it's
about what you keep so we really looked
at our finances dropped them right down
and then it allowed us to have a much
better lifestyle yeah
i mean three in rk is it's not a massive
amount of money i mean we do that
days before with the company
lifestyle right it's not about having
it's i mean
it's not about having hundreds of
thousands of pounds a month about having
an income that's going to provide you to
have a roof over your head and live a
life
exactly and even in the worst case
scenario if you have loads of voids and
stuff
it'll still cover our bills so we've got
financial security
freedom all the time
now because construction stopped for two
three months
yes yeah
we would have to still pay our bills and
contractors
and staff and bans and insurances
because we managed to cut that
before it all happened we've got no debt
at the moment
what did what did you think when you
first heard about rent to rent on
youtube and you saw my videos did you
did you think straight away that makes
sense or do you think that's weird i
just thought i can't believe that we
haven't
seen this before yeah and then the next
thought was who the hell is going to
give me a house to do this
yeah and we were thinking and thinking
and thinking and the first two after the
jb
those first two came in the first week
when we got back a holiday
so we took one went to view another one
from gumtree
and we signed for that one about six
days into the refurb of the first one so
we had two on the go at the same time
and so we changed the carpets we went
full full out with them full
redecoration we upgraded everything
i mean we had so many materials
so we could really utilize what we
already had which made it a lot easier
what advice would you give to someone
that had watched my videos understood
the concept of rent to rent
but had the same issues where they don't
know exactly what to say to the landlord
they don't know how to secure one
what would be your best advice you need
to be
more confident i would say sales is a
big part of it
the value is the biggest thing i mean
our landlords even upgrade the
electricity board for them all at our
expense because we can do it relatively
we do all the certificates we do
absolutely everything so it's truly
hands off
i mean we've not only spoke to our
landlords through the pandemic i've
never even called them or
emailed them because you know what i
should wait
we guarantee them that rent and that
will never change we've never
sort of struggled to pay them so you
know why it's not broke don't fix to do
it
would you say that would you say that
the property investing side of things
and
rent to rent has it brought you guys
closer as a couple
yeah i mean we spent a lot we spend all
our time together we work together and
played together um
but this has been probably together yeah
so this just made it it's just freed up
so much time i mean the dog gets walked
in the daytime every day now those
little things you know where you can
you don't dread a monday anymore or
anything i don't even look forward to
friday because every day
has got the same positive outlook on it
when you wake up really you know you're
kind of
do secure because we don't have the
staff we've got the assets working for
us
they never sleep yeah they're never ill
they don't phone in sick you know they
always pay out
sometimes a few rents may be late but
we're not gonna raise with anybody
have you done it did you out of interest
have you done it as a company or did you
set up a new company or you didn't get
as
it says entity yes great
that's interesting and what do you
reckon is the reason because i know i've
been messaging on facebook saying
come on come to an event you know i want
to meet you guys come to an event and
and for for one way for one reason or
another it's never happened
um did was that a deliberate choice did
you think no i'm just
really online or i think so yeah deliver
it because we wanted to prove you
that the videos i don't know i don't
know
there are plenty you know
why did you want to prove that that's
just the personal goal thing
just to try and see if we could do it
yeah um yeah we just through
we would come just for the connections
to have a chat you know
we didn't feel like there was gonna be
more content for us
because we gathered everything online
yeah and i've been around hmos for the
best part of the decade i've been
building up to 18 bedrooms for the
people
we've kind of knew them inside out it's
just all we didn't know was
entertainment possible yeah do not know
about it till this late in life
now i could have been doing this ten
years you know you've been in the in the
property industry you've been around
hmos you get hmos
so it was really just kind of like the
rent-to-rent side of things which you've
got just
about one little piece of the puzzle
changed everything
i'm deliberately at the moment i'm
getting people on winners wednesday
like you like the one from last week
same story
he's i've never met him he's never been
to an event he's literally just consumed
my content on youtube and i
like you i want to prove to people that
actually this isn't that
difficult it's about taking action and i
put out
so freaking much online for free
what else can you tell us you know
everything
you need is online and you'll only be
able to answer that question when you
actually attend right
yeah but here's an interesting point
though
i mean yes you've been you've been in
property for the last for the last
decade and stuff so you've got a lot of
foundational there around buildings and
hmos which has served you really really
well
what do you think and there's i don't
mind on what your answer is on this it's
cool it's just a disquestion
like you've not done paid training
because one of the accusations i get a
lot is
why would you pay for something when you
can just do it online for free and of
course i've got my beliefs and opinions
on that and i can answer that very very
um
you know powerfully because i believe in
paid training
what would you guys say as people that
have been successful literally from my
youtube channel which is amazing what
would you call it
i would say if you have no idea
no clue whatsoever about property go and
get trained
yeah the thing is people will learn
differently as well some people need to
be shown
and then it goes in a lot easier some
people are for reading i mean
i i spent the best part of thirty
thousand pounds at university on it i
can't
say it's a vain degree but it's probably
not as valuable as having some property
training if you're
a person person that learns from
probably directors more yeah i think the
only thing that i would add on to any
property training is
you know basic diy construction
technology because
most of what we do is building a house
to make sure it lasts five years
we do that ourselves i mean i don't do
the electrics obviously but we'll fit
bathrooms or change things
if you have a fundamental foundation in
construction technology even if it's
just a broad
look it will do you really well in rent
to rent because you'll know what the
problems are with a complaint
or if
yeah no that makes sense i think the
same as the last guy that i spoke to he
he's been in property for like i think a
decade or something he's built up a
portfolio
and then he came across my youtube
videos studied the different techniques
lease options rent to rents packaging
with what he already knew he tweaked
what he was doing and he credits me
but at the same time he didn't actually
do any of my training um
so it's interesting to get a different
mix i mean i think as well
and i get that you guys will you're like
a social experiment because you've
become successful you've done it off of
the back of youtube
which is awesome and it's good to prove
that's possible i personally think and
i'm just going to say this
if six months ago you had done some
training i think you would have not only
got there quicker i know you got that
quick anyway
but i think connections that you'd have
made deals that you viewed that you've
been
the only thing that misses is the
connections yeah
potentially you would have you've
probably met come across some deals that
don't quite work for you you could have
for instance package them and sold them
and the fact that
if you do all of it is 10 grand
it's like the roi on it so that's my
perspective but it's great to get
different people's perspective
yeah we were saying this this morning
that the roi on the train
i mean in property 10 rounds quite a
small amount of money
yeah on the grand scheme of things over
the last last scale
if you're doing property it's not a
get-rich-quick scheme this is a viewing
for the long haul you know it's a
large thing to build but yeah 10 17
you can pay a pound for the crash course
you can pay 10 pounds for my book
you can pay 95 pounds
the crash course knackering i think i'll
be dying after few hours
honestly you know what what i am going
to do
is have a part two after you've done
some training and just see
what your perspective is then because
you've proven that it's possible which
is amazing
and and to be honest many people have i
get stopped in the street all the time
from people saying
i watch your videos online and i'm now
financially free you know it's very very
common it happens
but the people that do this i don't have
people that do the training and say
i didn't need to do that people say
actually you know what
i could have potentially got here
without but i'm so glad that i did
because i learned so much more i made
connections i got there quicker on me
um no that's the thing the only thing we
miss is this has been quite a lonely way
to get through it because we haven't
been around that many people that are
doing the same thing
yeah they speak funny about it they have
no idea they just tell you to be careful
and what about this and you know the
usual things
yeah we're trying to explain at
christmas to a lot of family members and
it just
it's so difficult then when you meet
people that are already in property
it's like you speak the same language
it's much easier to kind of get things
across
because you've utilized things like the
facebook group and you've utilized
not only the youtube videos but you've
also you said that you made a joint
venture just through literally my
property facebook group
which is all free 28 000
28 000 property investors on the group
you can chat you can communicate it's
free
exactly today's really i'm really glad
to see that you've utilized the free
stuff and it's helped
um what do you think has been the
hardest part of
of the whole process over the last six
months
beginning i would say is the belief
if you believe that it's going to work
or not and be confident
right yes finding the right deal and
landlord as well i mean everything has
been so different
that the situations are just completely
different and it's building that rapport
and a lot of times one little thing
won't quite work out
you just put it at the beginning but you
kind of get used to failing
failing failing failing
having a network of people other
investors to be able to bounce deals off
each other
hold each other's hands hold each other
accountable i think it's really good so
it's great to have seen your presence on
the
on the facebook group um yeah i like to
help as well if i see a question that i
think i can answer
using just my whole experience i'll i'll
chip in you know maria does the same
we know a lot about construction we know
about some of the tenant issues and
stuff so
i always see you answering the when when
someone comes on with it it's too good
to be true or
this is to you know i always see you
jumping on and saying actually here's my
story
oh yeah we're kind of living it so
here's what it is yeah well i appreciate
that i appreciate that
i've got so many i've got so many
naysayers on social media i i can't
respond to them all so it it
like a huge we'll call it a debate a
huge debate overnight
like 110 comments to get through with
this couple of guys saying that
it must be [ __ ] or whatever and
eventually you know it kind of died down
and i'm not preaching anything i'm not
saying we're
rich from anything but the strategy
works can't argue with it
it doesn't work you're trying to make
out uh now during the lockdown
you're in the pandemic rental end
doesn't work at least option doesn't
work it's all [ __ ]
i mean we didn't have any problems we
still have
all the rest paid we are on plus every
single month during the long term
but it's happened it doesn't work
because it does work
to do it right yeah
it won't work if you keep saying it
won't work though
and you've got to get it to stack the
numbers have to be not
really win-win i mean it has to be
passive for the landlord so it's going
to have some money off the rent isn't it
yeah yeah because all of ours stack at
fifty percent occupancy they still
pay the bills and they pay the rent so
even at two rooms we don't worry about
them
yeah they're never empty so even when
one's there's one room you tend to get
a change overrun quite often in the
house but it's still
a full-on identity even even some of
them on three rooms are still making 500
a month
now so the fourth room is just like
another 400 pound top which is
unbelievable really i mean i i don't
know another way where you can uh
make that kind of cash flow that quickly
without buying an asset you know yeah
yeah
you have to time it up for such a long
time compared to that
with yeah 15 grand so we saved up
so we can buy one property and then we
watch your videos
for buying the property we're gonna
actually use for enter and the lease
options and let's just go out and
ask everybody you know ring the estate
agent
and just try that way and we did find
straight away too
and i completely changed our life
if you want to make three and a half
grand a month and you want to do that by
saving up and investing even if you get
10
return on investment which most
investors would say is very decent that
means you're gonna have to have
350 000 pounds to start with
yeah absolutely brilliant what would be
your kind of like final
words of advice to again people
listening in i mean i
think winners wednesday is such a great
thing because i've become successful
through property i share my stories i
share my mistakes i vlog what i do
but sometimes people might think yeah
but you're just special or you're
you know somehow have the magic touch
but the fact that the reason i do
winners wednesday every week is to show
that actually
it's not about me it's about the
strategies the strategies do
now i do teach them very well but it's
the strategies that work
i mean have you have you see has there
been any particular winners wednesdays
that you saw that really inspired you or
were there any
ones that you thought were the ones at
the beginning with james armstrong
yeah i spoke to james actually rather
because i was calling anybody and
everybody to try and get
something going on yeah
james is a really good friend of mine
and very close he did the he's done the
academy
he's been on the youtube channel now
multiple times so uh he's very
approachable and i think most people are
if someone
in this industry everyone wants to see
everyone succeed
and such people have got a small
competitive mind but i find in this
space everyone actually
wanting other people to succeed yeah
we're strange coming from construction
to this because it's a complete polar
opposite in construction
you get ripped off if you like them
very very much more difficult industry
isn't it yeah there's literally every
company
every agent tries to rip you off at the
end there is
always an invoice that is not paid you
know and that could be
the whole profit for our company so
yeah that's why again
cynical people it's like why are you
teaching if this is possible
what what what and it's like because i'm
not competitive i want other people to
see
so in wanting other people to succeed
what would be your final words of advice
wisdom
to anyone watching this right now stick
to it
if you really want to succeed just get
on with it
don't find excuses just just
get out there and get yourself deals
because you might ask
200 people but that one last one
will be the one that will say yes yeah
and we've probably failed more times
than most people ever even try so
you don't celebrate your failures but
there's so many of them they always lead
to a success in the end
gonna keep trying brilliant love that
hey guys thank you so much for coming on
windows on a wednesday you know what the
the sound quality has not been
incredible so obviously we'll put it out
because the content's been so rich we'll
put it out but i'm sure at some point
we'll be able to meet and we'll do
do a part two um
we'll give you a shout out awesome and
get yourself to some training
now you've proven your point folks
we wanted to come when we got 10.
get out of here you'll get 10 much
faster just do some training i'll pay
for it even just do it
not about the money for me it's all
about the significance so you should
definitely
consider it yeah okay and then you'll
ten times what you've done in the next
six months
thank you folks lots of love see you all
thank you bye